مغازي هذه الصور لمحاولات ها الاولى
المواطنين
بايادي عاريه اخراج ذويهم كما نتابع في
هذه الصور من تحت الانقاذ لهذا الطفل الذي
هناك محاوله
لانقاذه نذكر بان هذه الصور هي من مخيم
المغازي الذي تعرض هذه الليله
لمجزره بلغ تعداد ضحاياها حتى الان ما جرى
في مخيم المغازي وكذلك البري
شهيدا حتى الان والتقديرات تقول ان
الحصيله سترتفع لان هناك ايضا اعداد كبيره
من المواطنين في هذه المنازل ما زالوا تحت
الانق تزعل مني لا تزعلش يابا قول حسبي
الله ونعم الوكيل الحمدله بخير
بخير قول حسبي الله حسبي
اللهد ي
في جكيت ابعتوها على
داركم
ايش حاضر اه امسك ام بعطيك بلوزتي يا خال
خذ اه يا
خال حبيبي حبيبي يا
[موسيقى]
خال الله اكبر ياال الله
اكبر خلص انت بخير حبيبي مين حبيبك احم
قول ياار قول
يا ي الله
يلا
حاجه ربنا
يخ الحمدلله رب حسبي
اللهد
والله كويسين انا بقوللك والله طلعناهم
كلهم بخير اخواتك بخير كلهم ومك
بخيرن
يطلع